[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Conan O'Brien here to my video blog
welcome to it here's what's going on in
my world really psyched about the final
season of Breaking Bad yeah I can hear
you through the computer I'm hosting a
viewing party for the premiere where
everyone has to make their own meth and
then then we'll judge to see whose is
the best I did this last season - it was
a lot of fun the party lasted 14 days I
was pretty excited to hear Batman's
gonna be in the next Superman movie yeah
yeah I wish I wish Batman could be in
everything that's why I created this
first segment I'm calling famous images
where everyone is Batman famous images
where everyone is Batman like check out
Abraham Lincoln his Batman
[Applause]
we got the sailor kissing the lady in
Times Square that pretty famous there go
both Batman right there's a Batman
kissing a Batman Neil Armstrong on the
moon Batman check it out Bigfoot man
everybody's Batman famous images where
everyone is Batman
I really like stuffed crust pizza but I
don't like eating the crust or the pizza
so last weekend I bought a bunch of
stuffed crust pizzas and sucked out all
the stuffing inside the crust it took me
forever and I was still hungry later so
if you like stuffed crust pizzas but
don't like crust or pizza just go out
and buy some cheese I'm tired of people
posting fail videos every time someone
messes up a little bit I wanted to do
something positive for the people in
fail videos so this next segments called
epic succeeds now pick succeeds this is
where I take fail videos and I play them
backwards so it looks like the person is
doing something pretty cool take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
here's something cool you can try if you
combine two swearwords you can make a
new word that sounds kind of like a
swear but it isn't that means you get to
say whenever you want you won't get in
trouble here's some I made theirs chick
there's fight and my favorite mother
bags dude all right this is the last
segment called scary animals with googly
eyes scary animals little googly eyes I
took a bunch of pictures of really scary
animals and I glued those googly eyes on
them
that you had when you were kids and arts
and crafts so here's a wolf right here
there's an alligator right there
check out this fish right here there's a
spider right there oh man pretty crazy
yeah there's a shark right here
and then finally I like this guy the
best the bear
and that spider still scared the [ __ ]
out of me